ah
okay I'd like to
call house rules committee to order
and the first thing on the agenda
is to
are we supposed to vote on the uh
minutes
okay exactly circulated okay the motion
before is to accept the minutes
has given to us all in favor I don't
suppose eyes have it
um the main reason we're meeting is to
approve the deadlines
for filing and uh
September
Paul
oh
do you have a position I'm just going to
ask you if we could
sorry thank you I really am having a
hard time today
um
technologically challenged
I'm hoping we could consider extending
the last day to file lsrs uh from the
15th to
is it the
23rd or 22nd 22nd so it would be a
two-week window rather than a one week
window
and
um it's it's solely because at that time
of year we've got lots of people who are
traveling we've got lots of people who
are fulfilling all the obligations that
they put off for the first half of the
year or elective surgeries or medical
appointments or stuff like that
and having looked back as far as 2017
there's only once that we had a window
that was that short and that was two
years ago
and I just thought it would be more
convenient for people and it also might
help OLS spread things out a little bit
and then the final thing I will note is
that if we end on Friday September the
15th at 4 pm Rosh Hashanah starts at
sundown
so I thought perhaps if we extended the
deadline to September 22nd then we would
not be getting into Yom Kippur which
doesn't start till the Monday
and that might
just
be a an accommodation that would be
viewed favorably by many people
oh
thank you Mr chairman um so
with respect to the to the deadlines um
I we did do this two years ago with the
one week we also did do it one time uh
in in the recent past I think it was
2016. uh may have been 2017.
um but the
part of part of the overall totality
here is too is that we have actually now
surpassed even last sessions
um historic record of retained bills we
have now retained 187 bills and that is
not even including all of the Senate
bills that are are still have yet to be
heard which as you know have to be acted
on in the second year session
additionally
my concern and and I know representative
Weber will will talk about this when we
come back in the fall to look at the
springs that spring deadlines but my
concern as well is
the second year traditionally you all
want to get out a little earlier than
the the legal deadline of June 30th as
well
um and I I am concerned about
um
more bills potentially being on filed on
top of
um the the additional normal second year
bills
in in keeping in mind of course that we
now
um according to Dave I think it was
something like 70 is he here
um I think 70 at least of the bills now
are filed through ask OLS
in the
online format of email so uh that is a
an additional capability that we didn't
really have pre-covered
um where ask OLS where they were taking
the filings in that regard so
um the only other thing if if you do
want to do make that move that's fine
then I am going to suggest that we push
back that last day to sign off to give
them because that's what gives OLS
heartburn as if we shorten that time
frame so if you want to change
um to the to the following Friday
which which is the 22nd
um then I would suggest that we would
need to go back on the third uh to the
10th
which actually we can't do because
that's a that's a
that's a holiday because the 11th is is
Saturday this year so the observed
Veterans Day is is on Friday so that
would need to change to Thursday the 9th
question for the clerk yeah
how would it be if we extended it to the
18th that Monday
that way they get a weekend to finish
over and finish any builds and uh
would that make it much simpler for
OLS or I it's it's it's entirely within
Europe from your experience I I think if
we're my my only concern about OLS is
that they have the corresponding
length to to get that extra you know we
talked about because right now the way
this is drafted they have 30 days 30
actual working days
um between the last day to file off and
the last day to sign off
um and this is a concern more so in the
first year of the biennium with the
number of working days that they have
um 30 Dave was ecstatic when I suggested
there were you know when I gave them
this proposal for 30.
um so it whatever you want to do is fine
I would just say that we would need to
change that corresponding
one of my concerns is I think we've seen
a lot of bills come to the committee in
this last session
um where a lot of not a lot but some
sponsors didn't do the work they really
should have done to make sure they're in
a proper form for the committee because
it's not oh well that's just
responsibility
to rebuild the engine with the car but
they'll tune it up a bit but they won't
rebuild it and uh maybe with this extra
weekend that give members a chance to
actually work on their bills and keep
them in the correct form so that we
don't have committees uh swapped with
amendments coming in to try to uh
put them in proper shape that's just a
comment
no comment I don't disagree
oh
I think the one week is fine four days
whatever it is that's when you're
sending the email right all your work
and your research should have been done
in the months before that so we're just
talking about the deadline to get the
emails and the requests and and as far
as getting the bugs out of the bill
that's the deadline for sign off right
there's a back and forth so you get the
bill back from OLS and you go oh no this
isn't right or they raise an issue with
it and that back and forth happens
through all of October and maybe even
the last week of September that just
seems like it's a sufficient amount of
time to me
I also don't want people filing 800
bills
in a Weber
this is really more of an inquiry I
don't think we had any less bills when
we squashed it into a week did we
um
any fewer bills rather
it's it's tough to say I
somewhat
um but again I I really want to stress
that
what's coming in the second year is
really is is what is going to be
important because in terms of what we
have for time
um you know if if you want to go right
to the end of June which is great for me
because that gives us more time to build
in that flexibility but the more
um
the longer you leave a window open for
filing I think there's going to be more
people that say oh well I didn't think
of this one a week ago but hey maybe
maybe I'll take a stab at it this time I
don't know I
I think you are more prone to the longer
the session is open the the more lsrs
you'll have
but again that's
that's for you all is the policy makers
to decide and I would just say uh to
representative Smith
point I this is just deadlines I we we
are really hoping this doesn't become a
football
nobody else
uh I'm sorry did you make a formal uh
motion
November 3rd to Thursday November 9th
any other discussion
or call a rolls
nothing's the last one
I thought it was was it one
I thought you did no oh
no
no Smith
[Music]
no
yes
we're back to the original
proposal
somebody want to make a motion
okay
the motion is to accept the
deadlines that we have before us
which is September 11th September 15th
November 3rd November 17th and January
4.
any discussion
okay
call the roll
yes
okay
is there any other business to come
before us
Mr chairman I I was just um I'm just
sort of thinking um not as a preemptive
thing because we'll need to come back in
the in sort of the winter time frame
anyway but I I know that uh
we've talked about it before so I wasn't
sure if um we might want to entertain uh
at this time a preliminary approval for
statutory study committees to have their
bills filed after the reporting deadline
because that will follow after our
filing deadline and this is something
representative Weber we usually talk
about so I I just thought that if you
wanted to bring that up now we could do
that sort of preemptively
I would be glad to make a motion so that
we don't have to deal with it later on
that um any statutory or study committee
that's has a filing deadline after our
after our filing period closes is
able to file legislation in in
connection with a majority report I'm
sure the clerk has the motion as we've
made it over the years and we can just
take care of it now and not have to have
people
running around trying to figure it out
later
we've got language
yes sir it's essentially it almost
verbena
okay and I'm assuming that's a emotion
okay all right yes okay
representative
okay any further discussion
represent Packard yes representative
shirtless yes representative Smith yes
representative otter yes representative
Osborne representative Sweeney yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Weber
representative evil yes motion is
adopted nine is zero
Weber other business section I just also
anticipating going forward
when the calendar is set for for next
term
um when when we said it this term
crossover was already set and so we
couldn't change that so I just plead
when you are negotiating with the Senate
to put another week on our end of the
calendar in a shorter term on their end
of the calendar because uh our bills
were really squeezed this term and you
know having had I think
60 or 70 bills in committee for the very
shortened period of time this term and
then you know my committee has 16 bills
from now till May uh it I think it would
be really helpful to house committees
that tend to be more rigorous in delving
into the matter in in bills to have as
much time as you can buy from us from
the Senate
so I'm just putting that down there now
it was it was really short this time and
it was
uh as you know uh the bills that are the
biggest the most complicated and have
the biggest fiscal notes are the ones
that always come out at the end and then
they're due and we had about three weeks
Max to deal with some of those bills
which were complex
so I would I would hope that if and it
wasn't anything we could do on our end
because crossover had already been set
discussion for another day
great
I have no emotions you'll be glad to
know
okay uh is any other business
if not
boy nobody wants to do anything today so
we want to Major promotions
we are returned
foreign